[music]
these drones and underwater and aerial
drones, they partially walked in the corridor
along which grain is exported from Ukraine, and
thus they created a threat
both to our ships, which should
ensure the safety of grain export and
to civilian ships that
are engaged in this. And we pledged to
ensure this  security But if you
excuse me for the simplicity of expression, if
Ukraine gets [ __ ] under this court,
we will be guilty, therefore we are not
talking about the fact that we stop our
participation in this operation No, we are talking about the
fact that we are suspending one of the
organizers of this work was
the Secretary General of the
United Nations  Nations and its employees
take an active part in the
work in this work for which we are
unconditionally grateful Let them then
work with Ukraine and Ukraine
must ensure that there will be no threats to
civilian courts and to
Russian supply ships
[music]
yes yes